[music playing]
GEORGE ANASTASIA: The Italian
American Mob of Philadelphia
was Philadelphia-based,
but it had tentacles
into southern New
Jersey as Far East
as the Atlantic City resort.
LOU PICHINI: In the late
70s where legalized gambling
came to Atlantic City,
this was like a treasure
trove for the mob.
JIMMY D: Atlantic City
went from a ghetto
to a very powerful Union city.
The Bartenders Union, the
Waitress Union, the Linen
Union, the Philadelphia
mob with Scarfo
wanted to own those
unions because then you
could go to the casino
presidents and tell them
we're going to have a strike
unless you kick up the us
x amount of dollars annually.
It was big money.
John McCullough
was a union leader.
McCullough took control of
the unions in Atlantic City,
and he wouldn't go along
with any of the mob's plans
of working with them.
GEORGE MARTORANO:
John McCullough
made the mistake in getting
his eyes on Atlantic City.
All's I know he was told to
keep out of Atlantic City.
He should have listened.
LOU PICHINI: Scarfo
goes to Long John,
wants to set up McCullough.
You do the murder.
Long John's going to willingly
accept that because this is how
he's going to prove
himself with respect
to becoming a mob member.
- People don't realize.
It takes a lot of
balls to walk up
put up a gun to someone's head.
I met Long John, and he said
you got balls like an elephant.
Basically, we got a
piece of work to do.
I want you to do it.
Do a murder.
With the guy that's
right next to the boss,
it's an honor to be asked.
And I said, all
right, no problem.
Got a box of flowers, so
I could leave the piece
and the silencer in there.
Trying to be like a
dump delivery guy.
We arranged to meet about
5 o'clock that night.
Long John, I think he had
his gold Lincoln that day.
I got in the back
nodded, at each other,
we proceeded over the
Benjamin Franklin Bridge
heading towards
Northeast Philadelphia.
Long John pointed out the house.
He turned around
and sat a couple
of houses down in his car.
I got out with the flowers.
I went up and
knocked on the door.
And as soon as John
answered the door,
he looked at me just like
you're looking at me,
and I just put the silencer
up to his forehead.
It was over and that was that.
Long John said, man, I
love you, I love you.
Handed me $5,000 in
cash said, listen,
buy yourself some suits.
- 60-year-old
McCullough was gunned
down nine days before
Christmas in his
Northeast Philadelphia home.
LOU PICHINI: The delivery man
kills him in front of his wife.
People were just
absolutely stunned by that.
You wonder what is the
darkness of the individual
who's a member of the mob.
- Long John got made and
became an initiated member
because of that hit.
He was worthy of being
part of the organization.
JIMMY D: He became Scarfo's
number one man on the street.
Long John definitely wanted
to control the whole business
of meth in every aspect.
Someone won't
cooperate, kill 'em.
We'll just take over
his whole operation.